All right. So, I wanted to create a tool for DGER who are thinking
about leaving the best orbit. With Ryan Beard's video clocking
1 hour and 30 minutes, the Wan's brain of your average DGER will
not make it. I have created a more condensed version to assist
in the deprogramming. Let's start with him leaking explicit images
for two separate girls. They dug should like, what do you got
to say about these logs? I heard um I found out that you leaked
nudes of a girl. Like dude, there have been threads on this.
This has been in the news. Like everybody knows this, dude. You're
not finding out anything new about me. Like understood that you
showed private pictures of her to two of your friends. Yes. Yes.
Okay. So that's part of it. In 2012, when Destiny was 23, he
shared in a group chat with a couple of his friends the messages,
"You want to see the sickest in the world? So many fan girls."
I had one that was 15. She wanted to meet and hook up. Dude,
she's 15. What the? But she sent me pictures that made it so
hard to say no. Then Destiny linked a picture of this girl in
a bikini in the chat and said, "Girl on the left, so hard to
say no. Going to get arrested one of these MLGs, man." Thank
you, Ryan Beard. Destiny also shared explicit photos of a troll's
high school sister to intimidate him. And so that was cute. So
I got on Google Voice and I gave him a call via Google Voice.
And I was like, "Hey, what's up, bro?" And he's like, "Whatever,
dude." He's like, "So you can Google. That's pretty cool that
you got my phone number or whatever. He must think you're like
super pro or whatever." And I'm like, "No way, dude. I just wanted
to talk to your dad or maybe your brother Jeremy or your sister
Emma." He's like, "Dude, that's not even like my family." And
I was like, "Oh, are you sure, dude?" And he's like, "Yeah, man."
I was like, "Oh, really?" And so I start sending him pictures
over Skype of his sister, like I guess on the volleyball team.
I got a ton of information on this kid. Like I know more about
his family than I know about mine. It's pretty funny. Um, so
he's like, "Whatever, dude. So you can Google my name. Like congrats.
You're pro." 10 years later, that kid came forward to tell his
story. And he's he's saying, you know, calling me, you know,
telling me my address, telling me that he's, you know, got friends,
and that he's thinking about buying a gun, coming to my house,
and that he knows where my sister goes to school, and that he's
going to come drive to my house. He's going to murder me, my
father, my brother, my sister, and my mother. and he's gonna
rap my mother and my sister and record all of it. Destiny shared
explicit videos of fellow streamer Pixie without her consent
and is currently being sued by her in federal court. He also
distributed videos of his then wife Molina without her consent.
well something I can't like I'm not going to go into detail of
anything but there's plenty of people that's wondering this but
I feel like it should be obvious. Um nothing has happened with
consent with anyone. Not me and not anyone else. Like like there's
been no consent. So that's something that people seem to wonder
about and I feel like that's something that people should know.
I guess that's it. Oh, anyone saying stuff like that? That's
like actual revenge. Um so no thank you. It's it's not anything
like that. So thank you. That's something else that
Um, yeah, that was really horrible. Actually, really horrible.
I take that very seriously. U, so anyone commenting about that
stuff because it's an actual traumatic experience, they're going
to they're going to get instantly and never met ever. 4 years
prior, Destiny admitted he shared Molina's nudes without her
consent. Okay, so a long time ago. So sometimes, so obviously,
okay, me and Mina send nudes to people. Um, me and Mina had a
conversation about there were a few girls we talked to. I was
like, "Oh, cool. Like we should record videos of like usage people.
Like it's fun." So we do this. Um, I kind of like have like my
little archive of like material that I'll send to people if I
want to. Um, there were girls that I talked to um, past that
that I'd send stuff of like either me or me and Molina. And Molina
talked to me and she was like, "Hey, um, if you're going to send
any videos to um, new girls that we haven't talked about, like
let me know that first." Um, because she wanted to be careful.
And I was like, "Okay, sure." That was fine. I didn't think of
it at the time cuz I didn't think it mattered. But if you're
going to send any videos to um, new girls that we haven't talked
about, like let me know that first. um because she wanted to
be careful. Okay, sure. That was fine. I didn't think about it
at the time because I didn't think it mattered. But I didn't
think about it at the time because I didn't think it mattered.
But around the end of 2011, Destiny assaulted a woman on his
live stream. I'm not using the word allegedly here because we
have video of him doing it and he has openly admitted that it
was assault. I would say that in my streaming career in the past,
like totally publicly, like I completely and totally like assaulted
a girl on stream before for like 5 minutes or whatever. I got
super drunk. Thanks again, Ryan. Destiny also has multiple victims
of recording instances without consent. Starting with the Grinder
hookup where you hear Destiny knock on the door all the way to
him leaving and he never mentions the recording. But I'm trying
to do this one piece at a new leak dropped on KF recording of
the Grinder
dude. That's uh that's
horrifying. That's horrifying stuff.
two uh grinder encounters and then there's the cherry stuff.
The grinder encounter uh how do you know is
Uh because you hear him walking up with his phone in his pocket
before he meets the person and then it's like hey hi and they
don't he never says hey I'm recording in my pocket. So uh to
my mind if he had sent messages if they had discussed beforehand
uh hey I'm going to record with my phone in my pocket they would
have there would be records of that. Yes. Do you know how Grinder
works? Have you ever been on Grinder? I have not. Okay. So, I'm
gay and when I use Grinder, if I ever redownload the app or like
sometimes like if I was haven't talked to somebody for some time
that it's just immediately erased. So, I don't know how he gets
lost. So, if you were planning to share those recordings with
other people, do you think you'd make an archive of that? Especially
as the guy who archives all of his conversations. Fellow streamer
Cherry also had recorded without her consent that leaked. She
has filed a police report in the state of New York. Destiny has
also choked out his girlfriend, doxed over a dozen people, and
made explicit violent threats to intimidate potential witnesses.
Yeah. I um for Anna, that's for just I'd if I could. I'd shut
the house and do it. Um but not for Anna. No people do her is
what you're saying. Yeah. No. What the like why would I even
want to do that? Like what am I want to kill her? What? Like
that's I do want somebody to kill though or laugh or so. There
you go. Apparently, what am I going to dox her? What do I want?
Somebody to kill her. So, that's how he thinks of doxing, right?
Doxing's really bad, but I'm going to try to dox Jtock and Queen,
right? Doxing's really bad. You heard that, right? Not for Anna.
Noxer is what you're saying. Yeah. No. What the Like, why would
I even want to do that? Like, what am I? What? Like, so if he
wanted somebody to kill them, he would dox them, right? Just
to give you a good idea of why he would do that to somebody.
Even if he went down to hold her to stop throwing instead of
hitting her, I'm almost 100% sure everyone would be saying the
same. He had to leave her. He is going, "Yeah, I of course, dude.
I wish I would have filmed my with Rachel. I wouldn't have any
cuz you guys would probably think I'm a abuser, too." Garren
[__] te cuz you better believe I had to choke her
out a few times. That got crazy. Hell yeah it did. And I guarantee
you that everybody in here would probably think I'm a crazy physical
abuser, too. Sure. Destiny also doxed Anna, a former partner,
sending his fans to harass her. Oh, okay. Also, heads up, this
is my only non-media blackout time. Okay, this is my only non-
media blackout time over media like this. Okay, somebody on Kiwi
Farms has made a thread of Anna. So, if you are obsessed with
Anna and you want to talk about her all the time, you chatter.
You can actually go to Kiwi Farms and you can go and post all
you want, read all you want. That go there, post about it, talk
about it. People put a lot of effort into categorizing and archiving
everything. There you go. Okay. And in the thread about Anna
that Destiny encouraged his fans to go message they doxed Anna.
And it was later revealed that at this time Destiny was secretly
in an ongoing relationship with Anna. So you acknowledge that
you've been with her for a year. I think. Yeah, we've had on
and off. Sure. In response to this, Anna texted Destiny, "You
literally ruined my life. You just doxed me on your stream. You
put me in danger." And Destiny responded to this by saying, "You're
doing it to yourself, and you're going to keep doing it to yourself."
Lastly, if this didn't tell you enough about Destiny, let me
show you what his friends say about him over the last 6 months.
All right. Today, we get to talk about someone I know. Maybe
new. I don't really know how it how it works. I feel like the
term content creator friend is very gay, but you know, I guess
that's the situation we're in.
Obviously, it's tough, but what occurred and what I've seen is
completely and totally
unacceptable and horrible. the
conduct. My heart, you know, aches
for the victims
involved. It's been a tough
period. I want you to know that everything I did in the New York
studio situation, you know, I wasn't paid for any of that. I
did it because I believed in it.
It's a bitter pill to swallow for
sure. And not only that, I like Pixie
was was a DGER. You know, you see me wear DGG
hat, wear
emblem, the omni liberal logo.
I mean, it's it's you know what what stronger confirmation do
you need? I mean, there's there's seemingly no DM where he outright
denies that he did this. I mean, maybe once again, there's some
missing puzzle piece that I'm missing. And if that is the case,
obviously, this video is going to be totally and out of date
at the very least. And I would be more than willing to make that,
you know, public, his his new response and show that he never
did this in the first place. But realistically speaking, like
Aerodite said that he did this, Pixie said that he did this.
Destiny seemingly is acknowledging that he did this and all the
messages. So unless there's some like grand conspiracy, you know,
against him, there's there's basically like two outcomes, which
is one that he did it, which is the most likely, and secondly,
he didn't do it, and he is having like a schizophrenic meltdown
or something like that. I have nothing to gain from being friends
with Stephen. I have literally had nothing to gain from the moment
that we've known each other. Like, don't get me wrong, Steven's
done a lot of good things for me personally on the low in terms
of behind closed doors and help me out with certain things. And
I'm always going to be appreciative of that. And you know, in
that regards, he's been very stand up for me. And I and I'm grateful.
But professionally, like outside of that, it's been pretty bad.
Like a lot of people want to stop working with me. A lot of people
want to complain about the fact. And I never cared about any
of it. Why? Cuz I just like Steen. I saw him as a friend. So
I was cool with it. I didn't care if people wanted to stop talking
to me. I didn't care if fans got mad. I didn't care if people
question. Didn't bother me at all. But when he engages in like
actual behavior that I think is reprehensible, and I'm like,
"Bro, what are you doing? This is stupid and his response is,
"I like to have fun. I don't care." Then there's just got to
be a come point where I'm like, "Art, then I just got to cut
you off because your definition of fun is toxic." You know, you're
not going to be forgiven for this anytime soon, dude. You're
just like immaturity is just crazy. Yeah, that's basically the
whole situation. Seems pretty seems like Destiny is a pretty
bad person. Wow. Big shocker. I know everybody's uh you know,
nobody's told me that before ever. Not one. Not one. Everybody
said he was he was awesome until this moment. though. But
um I never thought it would be without
Steven. In all my visions of the future, I always saw him as
um being by our side
um as we moved on to these
things. I always envisioned it. It's what I wanted.
But I don't despair because I know some of you are still out
there and and there are good creators, good people to
follow. It it's certainly not going to be the same. I'm not telling
you it's going to be the same at
all. But um I'm I'm begging you, please don't become apathetic.
Don't lose
If you don't mind, I'm going to take a sip of my iced tea.